um there was a kid who used to go to
providence email that just got shot that
we just found out about and it was very
very sad to hear about but in my mind i
was i was thinking that
man we should you know inspire more
people to you know like stay in school
and you know practice and you know study
and work work hard
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing to you the issues and awareness
that you need to know about violence on
the south side of chicago but also to
build a community center to raise as
much money as possible to build a
community center on this block called o
block it's called o block because it's
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs took
the o and start calling it o block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it to opportunity
block i want to thank fox for giving me
the opportunity every day to bring to
you rooftop revelations where i share my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions as it
relates to matters in chicago and across
our great country and every now and then
i get to share with you some very
special guests like today today i want
to share with you a young man who we are
all so excited about and his
accomplishments his name is mario hoover
mario thank you for being here thank you
for having me can i go ahead and tell
everybody what you did yes all right so
mario is here because he scored
a perfect
36
on the act that's right the school test
that they take for achievement
scholastic achievement he scored at 36.
and i want to talk to him because i want
to talk about how did he do it what what
what his school that he went to and all
that so let me just jump right in so
mario um
[Music]
you are a student where of providence
ain't now probably the same we we all
love providence email that's one of the
schools that president reagan uh really
talked about with dr adams and we've had
your principal on here uh tell us about
going to school at providence st mail
how was it
well i've been at probably the same mail
since third grade um now i'm a junior
it is it's rough it's rough sometimes
but it's fulfilling in a way that's
academically you know
rewarding yeah of course the 36.
i know that's right yeah um so it was a
struggle at first though because coming
from
a school that i really didn't have to do
much homework at and then going to
property samuel and they grade you on
homework so you failed if you don't turn
in your homework yeah it was really
rough um adjusting but i got to the
point where i was able to you know um
achieve and you know really take off
yeah do you feel like that sometimes
some students maybe
uh they're not achieving in other places
uh because they lower the standard like
providence st mill has this high
standard this is
this is the standard
meet it they're not letting you make
excuses
all the time
um at providence email they really
oppose the fact that this is where you
should be at this is where we are at um
they make us
study and practice for the act um i've
been practicing since like sixth grade
for the apt so they of course they um
they hold us to high standards they
reward us um we have the um arms
assembly
every quarter and they reward us for our
achievements so it's a it's a very
rigorous process but it's a very
rewarding one as well yeah so
a lot of people would think well this is
just some smart kid he's probably always
been smart he's never had the struggle
have you ever had the struggle with
school and and
and and
how did you get through that
okay well i would say that third grade
year the year that i went to providence
team i was my most um
struggle bus it was struggle bus for
real um yeah i had to um acclimate to
work and you know really get adjusted to
that environment and then i got
diagnosed with adhd and then after that
i was really like you know what focus
and hone in on my craft and that's what
i did and i feel like after that is when
i really started to you know study and
which is really a rough thing for me
because i never had to study and then i
probably said well i realized yeah maybe
you should study um do your work and
then you know
i achieved what i achieved and at
probably the table you have um people to
look up to those high scoring people who
you always see now i guess that i'm one
of the achievers yes those high
achievers um and you like you look at
them you go i want to be like them yeah
and that's what the providence email
community develops um
that's what they have accomplished
that's good so i want to talk a little
bit about um you know you said you had
adhd and there's a lot of kids in our
community
how did you
get the tools to work through that like
you got this 36 yeah with adhd
you must have did
something to like what practices what
discipline what thing i want to know
what did you do how did you do that well
okay i would say it really hindered me
um up until the point where my teachers
really were like okay mario we know that
you struggle but we know we see so much
potential in you and we want you to you
know excel so i went after school you
know i got help writing essays you know
working out that time and balance to you
know really
you know get the highest possible score
i can and to um achieve the best
way that i can yeah so so not only are
you gifted
at school sure but you're you're also
gifted musically too tell us about that
real quick yeah so after school when i
go to my teachers i always go to a music
teacher and talk about music and do
music things
i am all i'm also an allstate
musician i let me a the illinois music
education association i achieved the
very high score of my audition so i got
to perform at peoria just this last
weekend
yeah it was very very fun so here it is
you
live in the neighborhood and we've
already talked in the past about
providence saint mail is in the hood yes
and you live in that neighborhood
garfield park and like me um
single parent mom
tell us about how has it been living in
the hood
but having a mother
really really push you because that's
how i if it weren't for my mom pushing
me yeah i know i would not be on this
platform insane so tell us a little bit
about that well my mother has always
worked very very very hard for me to um
basically do everything that i do um
she's worked overnight and then she come
home she does hair and then you know
that she used to go to go puff drive
around tired all the time and it really
inspired me to you know
do do my work essentially and it
inspired me to you know you can push
through all your you know hindrances all
your challenges you know just achieve
what you want to in life yeah
so
a few more questions
so
between you and some of the other kids
in uh garfield park i know you see a lot
of kids or know of kids who have been
shot and killed or know of kids who
just don't make it
what do we what do we need to do to help
our community to begin to thrive so the
other so we can have other kids get 36s
i would say do what providence email
does probably say male is a community
that inspires um there was a kid who
used to go to providence email that just
got shot that we just found out about
and it was very very sad to hear about
but in my mind i was i was thinking that
man we should you know inspire more
people to you know like
stay in school and you know practice and
you know study and work work hard and
you know stay out of the streets yeah
you know
so it really touched me to keep working
hard and want to inspire others to be
better so
with all of this hard work and a 36 what
do you what do you want to do because we
want to help you do it so what is it
that you want to do with this 36 what
college do you want to attend what do
you want to major in okay i want to go
to um columbia university in new york
i want to major in neuroscience and
behavior and minor in music um i find
that there is so much power in music but
also i find um me and my mother used to
watch house as a child and i was
inspired by all the doctors achievements
in-house so i
i want to inspire others how i was
inspired through music and through that
um as medical medical education wow so
columbia university in new york so we're
going to make sure we get in touch with
them
i'm gonna do my part to help you get
that scholarship that's that's awesome
so man listen
thank you for coming out in this cold
weather and coming on top of this
rooftop and let me interview you we are
so proud of you and so proud of your
accomplishments and thank you for
working hard and hopefully um we can
help some other kids to do the same
thing all right god bless you god bless
all right so listen as i always say
thank you for tuning in to rooftop
revelations god bless you god bless
america and until tomorrow
peace
you